بعد مداولات استمرت لاربعه ايام انتهت
جلسات مؤتمر خارطه الطريق تجديد عمليه
تفكيك نظام الثلاثين من يونيو النقاشات
شامله التشريع وسياسات والاليات والمجالات
والقواعد والاجراءات لتجديد تفكيك النظام
المعزول يعني هدف رئيسي من اهداف اي
انتقال
من اجل فتح الطريق
عليها بوسائل غير مشروعه ويدخل استراتيجيه
جديده وهيك الجديد وتطوير للقانون
والاجراءات والكفاءات وطنيه قادره وفقا
مبادئ سياده حكم القانون والشفافيه
والعداله
ما رشح من معلومات حول التوصيات انها ركزت
على اجراء اصلاحات عميقه في المنظومات
العدليه بكافه مستوياتها جرائم الفساد في
المتعلقه بفساده في تعيين الاجهزه العدليه
النائبه العام القضائيه وزاره العدل هي
عملت عمل التوصيات متعلقه باعاده ازاله
التمكين في هذه المؤسسات طبعا عشان نصل
اهدافنا لابد من محاكم من محاكم خاصه
ونيابات خاصه وشرطه خاصه
التوصيات شملت اصلاح القوانين المنظمه
للقطاع الخاصه وانهاء الواجهات الدينيه
للنظام المعزول ومراجعه اجهزه الضبط
والرقابه واجراء مراجعه لقطاع النفط
والتعديل ومحاسبه المتورطين في اكتساب
الاموال بطريقه غير شرعيه غير ان التركيز
على المنظومه العدليه فيها ازاله لهواجز
النفوذ عناصر النظام المعزول بحسب البعض
اجمل التوصيات ايضا
كيفيه ازاحه وجود اجهزه عدليه يعتقد انها
تنفذ السياسات النظام القديم
وترعى مصالح النظام القديم وتؤسس لهذا
الامر هذا لم يكن ورد في التجربه
25 اكتوبر
مؤتمر التجديد لعمليه تفكيك النظام ال30
من يوليو خرج بتوصيات مثلت خارطه طريق
لانجاز اولى القضايا المرجئه من الاتفاق
الايطالي التوصيات سيتم تسليمها للجان
متخصصه من اجل مؤامتها الدستوريه وقانونيا
لتحويلها للنصوص في الاتفاق النهائي محمد
عثمان العربيه الخرطوم